Vanessa Bryant has a special message for
her daughter's on her first Mother's Day
since she tragically lost her husband
Kobe Bryant and their 13 year old
daughter Gianna back in January she's
amazing in a heartwarming Instagram post
the mama for shared this photo a collage
that her oldest Natalia created for her
she captioned the picture quote I love
being your mama at Natalia Bryant Gianna
Bianca and Capri hashtag my world you
are all the very best of mommy and daddy
Vanessa showed off some of her special
gifts on her Instagram story one being a
sweet present from her daughter's a book
titled why I love mom
she wrote over the picture quote I love
you so much at Natalia Brian Gianna
Bianca and Capri Thank You Vanessa also
thanked Natalia for gifting her with a
charcuterie board to enjoy throughout
the day Vanessa thank family and friends
for thinking of her on Mother's Day
Ciara gifted her this bracelet that has
nicknames of all of her four girls
Gabrielle Union and Dwyane Wade sent her
a beautiful bouquet of flowers as did
Rachel Zoe and good friend Lala Anthony
I talk to her every single day
and just you know continue to pray for
her and stay positive for her she I tell
her every day she's the strongest woman
I know and I'm really really proud of
just how she's handling everything and
just want to continue to be there you
know as much as I can for her as a
friend she's just an amazing and amazing
human being just just amazing
this isn't the first special occasion
the family has celebrated since Kobe and
Gianna were killed in a helicopter crash
along with seven others on the morning
of January 26 last week Vanessa turned
38 and in honor of her birthday she
revealed that she recently found a
letter from her late husband that she
never read before in the caption she
said that she found it ironic that quote
Kobe had a photo of me drawn with an
angel holding me up by an artist on the
cover goodnight
great date night you guys get to go home
now and relax yeah we know we don't
really get a chance to really kick it
without the kids man so we might might
go out hang out for a little bit the
family celebrated what would have been
Gigi's fourteenth birthday May first
Vanessa shared this photo captioning it
quote mommy loves you more than I can
ever show you you are part of my soul
forever I miss you so much every day
[Music]
you